Flemings and Memorial University can
tell us about those complexities
Albert
um okay yeah so I'm going to be talking
about
um related to that so
um
you know how how we can use like
resolution groups in order to analyze
stat solvers we're going to talk about
using different persistence to analyze
different algorithms
to be sort of related to sat here
um yeah okay so
integer programming problem
um you're given this input a system of
linear inequalities
um these form a Polito in-dimensional
space just like take the intersection of
all the uh points that satisfy the
linear inequalities and this gives you
this big
convex object with flat sides
um
and you're also given a direction and
this is sort of the direction you want
to optimize in
um and you want to Output an integer
point which maximizes in this direction
so in particular it's really important
that we want to Output an integer Point
here
um so this would be a solution this
little star guy here that's the
solution in this direction
um and this is a super General framework
like it's very easy to encode most NP
hard problems as integer programs and so
you know yeah it's NP hard to solve
um you see contracts this with linear
programming which is like uh P complete
basically
um so in linear programming we want to
Output rather than just outputting an
integer solution here in linear program
we just want to Output any solution in
the polytote so the for integer program
this is the solution and for linear
programming
it's got one for this
okay
um
yeah so
even though integer programming is NP
hard
um or NP complete actually
um just like in sat practitioners are
able to solve uh practical instances of
integer programming pretty routinely
so how is this done
um
the general idea for all of these
algorithms is to reduce from uh integer
programming to linear programs
um so the for this we're going to need
this notion of an integer Hull of a
polytope
uh so the Airship Hall is like
um uh you look at all of the integer
points that are contained in the polytop
and you take the convex Hall of them so
the smallest convex body uh that
contains all of the integer points and
now as you can see the vertices of this
polytope are the integer points that are
in this in the initial polytope
um yes it is a polytope and since the
vertices of the integer Hull are the
integer Solutions if we run linear
programming
um on the integer Hull we get an integer
solution so this is a reduction from uh
integer programming to linear program so
if there's a way to take a general
polytope and reduce it to its integer
Hull that we can just run linear
programming on it and get an integer
solution solve integer linear
yeah yeah you can see that that's the
solution
um yeah so what modern integer
programming algorithms try to do is to
do this reduction to turn a polytope
into its integer Hull
um
and so one way to do this uh was
suggested by gamoran vital in the in the
70s and 60s this was to add cutting
planes to this polytope
[Music]
um
so what's a cutting plane so basically
it's a linear inequality that lies
outside of its outside the polytopes
it's every point in the polytope
satisfies this linear inequality
um and we're going to require that the
the coefficients of the linear
inequality are relatively prime
um and the right hand side is rational
and what we can derive from this is
um yeah the uh you you can derive ax
graph with the ceiling of B you can
round up the right hand side and this is
just because if you had any integer
point which satisfied x squared equal to
B
uh then since the the call stations a
are integer
um then any solution is going to an unit
or solution will also satisfy ax grain
with the ceiling of B just remove the
fractional part yeah
it's not that if they're not relatively
valid it's just that it's not optimal if
they're not relatively so yeah so the
relatively relatively prime part we can
ignore that but it gives you this really
nice property
um uh it explains kind of what's
Happening geometrically
um so if a is relatively prime
um then what happens is you take so this
is a screen B here
um and what a CG cut is is taking this
inequality and just shifting it upward
to the nearest integer point this this
only happens if they're relatively
practiced it's like the as Russell is
saying just the basically the optimal
thing you can do with this
fair so this is what happens you shave
off corners of the public toe and you
should think of these
um yeah CG Cuts is just cutting off
corners of the polytope and we want to
keep doing this until eventually we get
down to the interval
okay another example that
um yeah and so
um
it's slightly out of order actually
um but uh vital showed that you know if
we add enough cutting planes then we are
eventually going to converge together
holes this is like complete for doing
this however uh it may take a very very
long time this was shown originally by
putlock and Bene potassium Roz for a
restricted case
um another downside to this is that it's
unfortunately numerically like pretty
numerically unstable and requires some
uh complicated heuristics to implement
this cutting Flames procedure
okay so what do modern uh integer
programming algorithms do most of them
implement this thing called branch and
cut
um and branching cut combines these CG
Cuts this this cutting planes method
with a branch and bound procedure
so it's going to alternate doing the
following two things first is this
branching procedure where we take our
polytope and we break it up into a bunch
of subpolytos
um the very the general framework is we
can just break them up however we want
but we're going to restrict this later
because
um
algorithms don't do this arbitrarily so
branching we take
um we start with that polytote P and we
break it up into a bunch of subpolytopes
such that every integer point is
contained in one of the sub pumps so
here's an example
there's P1 P2 P3
um and you can observe here these are
the three different polytokes we get and
all integer points are preserved
and then we're left with these three
polytopes
um and then we do the second step cut
hence the name branching cut so we
refine each of these polytopes by
including some additional CG Cuts or
cutting points
effect and we keep doing this over and
over again until eventually we find an
integer integer solution or we run out
of points and it's not satisfied
um yeah so here I gave you a very
general definition of this branching but
in practice branching is done by
splitting on an arbitrary integer linear
inequality so we we pick a linear form
ax and we branch on whether it's greater
than equal to b or less than or equal to
B minus B plus one or B minus one has
same thing
um and we're going to require that a is
integral and so is
okay and in fact like in Branch
um in practice this is this is maybe
even Overkill like what people will
often do for this branching step is just
like the standard dpll branching and
dpll branching in this geometric setting
corresponds to just picking a variable
and branching on whether it's greater
than or equal to one or less than or
equal to zero and so on and so forth so
branching on the value of single
variables but
doing it with linear inequalities this
much
okay
um yeah so that's how roughly how uh
practical integer programming algorithms
work
um and so we want to analyze these we
want to understand like how good these
algorithms are what they can do
um
so these modern integer programming
algorithms are kind of a complicated
mess of heuristics they they do this
branching cutting but we need to choose
how to branch and how to cut and that's
really really difficult and because of
these heuristics it makes this is you
know similar in sad as well it makes
like directly analyzing these algorithms
very difficult because we have to worry
about like which heuristic we used here
and here and here
um and that's kind of becomes a little
bit infeasible
um so instead we can turn to proof
complexity
um so we can use the following
observation that if the polytope
contained no integer points so the
polytope was unsatisfiable
um then if we run the integer
programming algorithm
um
then it has to because the integer
programming algorithm is deterministic
it has to like its execution Trace has
to actually be a proof of the fact that
the
um polytope contained no integer points
it has to Output this thing like it has
to say there's no integer points in this
polytip okay and so the transcript of
the algorithm yeah is a proof that
there's no integer points in the
polytote
and this also even works in the
optimization case where you know if if
we if the algorithm outputs that like
some point x is the optimal thing then
it sort of includes a proof of the fact
that there's no better solution so this
you can even use this idea to analyze
optimization
um yeah and so this leads to complexity
um so instead of trying to analyze the
algorithm directly we want to formalize
the techniques that the algorithm uses
into a proof system
um and then Analyze That proof system so
particular lower bounds in the size of
proofs in the corresponding proof system
imply run time lower bounds in the
algorithm
um so this sort of approach dates back
uh all the way back to the tall uh who
started doing this with um The Cutting
planes uh proof system
so a cutting planes refutation of a
polytope which doesn't contain any
integer points is just a sequence of
polytopes such that each polytope is
obtained from a previous one by
including a new uh CG cut
and the size of the proof he's just the
number of polytops in the sequence
so a little picture is here's the first
polytope
to be out of CG cut we rule out those
points another one we roll at these
points another one we rule out the
entire polytope it's empty and the size
of the proof was three this is Victoria
kind of what's going on
it's introduced by the tall
um again the first lower bounds approved
by a putlock and beneathon bras for
um the case where each CG cut has small
coefficients and we're going to get back
to this small coefficients theme in a
little bit
um yeah and so this captures these uh
original cutting planes algorithms I
mentioned that only use CG Cuts but no
branching
um so in 2018 we introduced this proof
system
um stabbing planes
um in order to model these branch and
cut solvers or to model the more uh
modern algorithms for integer
programming
so a serving planes proof is extremely
simple
um at each step we pick an arbitrary
integer linear inequality so A and B are
integral
um and we branch on whether that
inequality is true or false over the
integers that is whether ax is less than
or equal to b or ax is greater than or
equal to B plus one
and then we recurse the two politics so
here's an example uh there's ax less
than because the B and X great group of
B plus one
and we have the slab this set of points
that lie in between these two things
and this slab is removed every time we
rehearse so just like how in cutting
planes we remove sides or like corners
of the polytope in stabbing planes we're
removing like mid sections of the
polytope
um because A and B are integral this
slab doesn't contain any integer points
and yeah so we get two polytopes and we
recurse on them and we keep recursing
until each until we've derived like each
of these polytops is empty basically
until we've certified the fact that
there's no integer points in them
um yeah
so you can you you can and I'll I will
get back to that in a second
um that's a good point
um
yeah so a stabbing plans refutation more
formally of a polytope with no integer
points is just a binary tree where for
each node you have some linear form ax
and uh as two outgoing edges one's
labeled with ax grain equal to B plus
one the other one's less than
um and uh we can associate with each
node
um a polytope which is formed by taking
the intersection uh taking the initial
Politoed p and intersecting it with all
the linear inequalities along that route
to Leaf Branch so for example uh here
you know this is p this is Politoed p
and then we go down this Branch we
intersect with ax going through the B
plus one and we get this particle so
this is the polytope correspondence node
and a stabbing planes uh refutation of p
is one in which each of the leaves is
labeled with the empty polytope
and this is like a sound proof system
um because if there was any integer
points in the initial polytope because
every time we remove the slab the slab
doesn't contain any integer points in it
if we could have derived the empty
polytop at each of the leaves
uh then this is a proof of the fact that
there wasn't any integer points to be
given
um
why are we taking the intersection of
like ax greater than equal to B plus one
like we don't want to satisfy ax less
than equal to B right yes
yeah so we're just picking some integer
linear inequality and you should think
of branching on whether the inner linear
inequality is true or false so on this
one this is corresponding to it being
true
um and this one's corresponding to it
being false roughly over over the images
[Music]
oh that's a great question uh yeah so so
at the end uh we can just run a linear
program at the end to check that the
polytope that you have like the
intersection of everything down the path
um actually does uh
doesn't have any points at all in it
or Farkas lemon also works
um
yeah okay and the the size of the proof
is just going to be the number of nodes
in there this is polynomially related to
the actual like bit complexity of
writing down
this is for the people attending on
social either like speaking the mic will
repeat the question
so uh how do you know that when you
guess this inequality you make progress
that you cut part of the polytop yeah so
that's a great question here it's just
like in like resolution proofs or like
sort of a non-deterministic thing on
um so the Practical implement the people
that are that are actually implementing
these algorithms they have to worry
about that but for me I just care about
like the existence of such a proof I'm
looking for the smallest such group here
so yeah you could do something that
definitely doesn't make progress but if
they're yeah
worst case measure
um
yeah okay so that was
um seven plans and so it seems like
cutting planes and Statin planes capture
different parts of these branch and cut
integer programming algorithms cutting
planes captures the actual cutting well
uh whereas stabbing planes captures the
branching
um so you might think maybe they're uh
different uh however it's not too
difficult to see
um that in fact from the perspective of
proof complexity these
um these cutting planes are kind of
Superfluous you can turn any cutting
planes proof of size s into a stabbing
planes proof of roughly the same size I
think the blow-ups by two or something
like that
um and this kind of goes back to
Albert's question
um
okay uh actually I'll say that in a
second
um yeah so in order to do this in order
to prove this theorem I'm actually going
to introduce a weaker notion of stabbing
planes which is going to be equal to
cutting points so the stabbing planes
query like one of these branches
um we're gonna say is path like if one
of the two sides of the query is the
empty poly tip
uh so this is not a pathlight query both
this and this are not empty
uh but this one is so this whole side
there's nothing left here and we
rehearse on this side and a path like
um stabbing plants proof is one where
every um query is path like and just
looks like one big long path because one
side has to be empty
okay so it's not hard to see the path
like stabbing planes is equal to cutting
plants
um how do we see this uh so if we have
uh some linear inequality here we take a
CG cut so we round up uh the right hand
side
then we can just look at the static
planes branch which is ax gray equal to
the ceiling of b x less than the ceiling
of B minus valid seven plans branch and
so we can just simulate each stabbing
Place each CG cut one at a time
um and get a path like that that's proof
okay so
um stabbing planes now seems pretty
powerful it can it can do the branching
but it can also like sort pretty
trivially simulate these uh cutting
planes so it might be natural to
conjecture that cutting plants is
that is quite weak uh it's a lot weaker
than than stabbing plants uh and this is
what we did in 2018 so
ever trust their conjectures
um so we conjectured that the site and
formulas are a separate example okay
um so the site and formulas uh you're
given a graph with an odd number of
vertices
um and it the the formula is going to
assert that there's a way to assign
edges to this graph
um such that each vertex has an odd
number of uh like
incident edges or Neighbors
so you write this down as a system of
mod 2 linear equations like this
um but then because you know there's an
odd number of vertices and you want that
each vertex as an odd neighbor it's like
a parody counting thing and it's
unsatisfied
yeah and these formulas are have been
really important in proof complexity
um
they were one of the first formulas to
be shown to be hard for resolution
um they're hard for AC Sarah Fraga uh
and yeah they've just kind of been used
all over the place and
um it had been a long-standing
conjecture that they uh required
exponential size uh cutting planes
proofs
um
on the other hand in this 2018 paper we
showed actually that there are that
should not be cutting planes that should
be stabbing planes that's I'm jumping
ahead a little bit
um okay so so that there are
quasi-polynomial size stabbing plants
purple sign so this number made look big
is it's pretty small
um compared to exponential okay so small
stabbing planes proofs of sight
um so this seemed like a good separating
example to us
um however
um
in 2020 uh daddu shintoari actually
showed that these quasi polynomial size
stabbing planes proofs of sight can be
translated into quasi-polynomial size
cutting blades
okay so refuting this long-standing
conjecture and yeah
um so this approach didn't work
uh so then maybe let's switch sides and
ask like maybe can every stabbing plants
proof be efficiently translated into
cutting plants can we actually just
simulate this branching that branch and
cut is doing with these like cuts at the
corners
um so we answer this positively provided
the coefficients are not too large uh so
each each linear equality doesn't have
like massive coefficients
[Music]
coefficient Supply
um
I have a question oh yeah oh yeah
okay
so the simulation of uh between the two
it holds that cozy poly but it's not
known to hold at Poly is it no so that's
a great open question I would love
somebody to give me an answer to that uh
yeah I'm not really sure I'm kind of
agnostic on whether that's true
um
yeah okay so so our main theorem is the
following it's kind of a complicated
statement but it's it's basically saying
that if the coefficients of a static
plane's proof are are not too large like
the coefficients of each inequality then
you can quasi-polynally turn any
stabbing planes proof into cutting
plants
okay
um more formally so if you have a
polytope and there's a stabbing plants
proof of size s which coefficient as
magnitude c
um then you get a cutting points proof
of this size where we have a dependence
on the diameter of the polytope and I'll
show you why that comes in it looks a
little bit weird initially uh but
um this is really where the
uh yeah this diameter blow up
is very related it's coefficient model
um yeah and so we get a nice crawling
from this so we get the first lower
bounds on bounded coefficient stabbing
planes proofs
um by just applying the known lower
bounds for cutting points
so we get lower bands for the color
formulas
um
and lower bounds for random uh log and
CNF formulas
well because in our lower bound paper we
also I mean we call it deduction you
know we were
right so we had lower bounds for those
two right yeah but that had to be a
balanced yeah yeah yeah so this can be
very very unbalanced this is allowing
just an arbitrary uh
tree so
at the end of the day it is it is a
reduction just to interpolation so it's
interesting that
yeah yeah yeah because I I did this is
where
unbalanced you know
yeah like this the the stabbing plants
thing was originally came from me and
antonina looking
at uh at your paper so yeah
but but like with balancing with the
balance tree you can you can
do some tricks on there but with the
unbalanced thing it's it's really weird
uh so I'll try to sketch the proof
uh
diameter seems a little bit cured me
because aren't there you know I mean
your Transformations
linear transformation that take injuries
and integers that that that greatly
change the diameter
yeah yeah yeah yeah there are
um
but I'm not sure if you can do these
within stabbing planes I think that's
roughly the problem you'd need to
represent that in the proof system
so so I'll show you
uh I can show you the proof in a second
um
small question so everything that you've
done uh the the simulation and
conjecture separation is between
tree-like proofs and dag-like cutting
planes proof
so it's uh how is it how is it is it
reasonable to assume that uh
there is no separate that daglai cutting
plane is not stronger than tree-like
stabbing plane uh that they're actually
equal
no I just um surprised that tagline
cutting planes is not stronger even than
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah originally
my intuition but it's sort of this like
top down versus bottom-up like
I guess okay
another way to think about this is that
um
you can view stabbing planes as this
tree-like RCP crew system where every
line is a disjunction of linear
inequality so you're allowed a lot more
line power
and and this uh additional
expressitivity of of lines is allowing
you to simulate these like bag like
steps and cutting planes
um
so but this is
a resolution over cutting planes is
equivalent to stubbing playing uh the
tree-like version Trina yeah I think
yeah
yeah the dag-like it's not known
probably not true
so I mean is there something known about
about separation between cut I mean this
is something I was working on way back
you know between
uh polynomial coefficients and
exponential coefficients for cutting
planes still a great open problem people
are still working on that today yeah
yeah
it's really interesting probably the
same thing might be true because looking
at your theorem you know the simulation
preserves the coefficient size
or no so it doesn't so the really
annoying I would love it to do that and
I can talk a little bit at the end about
like why it doesn't do that but it turns
yeah like low coefficient stabbing
planes proofs into very high coefficient
cutting planes
[Music]
yeah so I don't I don't say the
coefficients of the of the resulting
cutting points but they do kind of
recursively blow up
um I'll say in a minute where that comes
in or
yeah
so I'll sketch the proof
um there's two steps uh so we showed the
cutting planes is equal to this path
like stabbing planes uh but we're
actually going to show it's equal to a
uh more General object that yeah seems a
lot stronger initially than path like
stabbing planes and then we'll show that
any boundary coefficient standpoints
proof can be made into this face-like
Statin planes proof this this more
powerful version seemingly more powerful
version of password
um so a stabbing planes query one of
these branches is is face like if at
least one of the two polytopes you're
left over with is a face of the
and the part the polytop that you
started with
okay so a face is just like one of the
sides so uh it's it's like a dimension
you've lost in the dimension
so I can show it with a picture uh it's
probably a bit easier so this is a path
like query uh remember you've shaved off
basically a side of Polito
on your your proof was a big long tree
um but a face like query like a path
like required that this side was
completely empty uh but a face like one
you you only require that
um that this side is a face so I may
have points exactly along the half space
that survives
um
yeah so yeah can you repeat the question
yeah
um for example when you branch on a
variable
the you know Boolean variable then it's
always going to be face like
yeah exactly so so when you branch on a
variable this but Russell is saying if
you branch on a variable then it's
always facelift yeah
so you just want you have like a linear
inequality and you want the only points
to survive that survive on one side are
those that lie exactly on the linear
inequality
yeah so so a face like proof yeah can
have you can actually recurse on both
sides it's not trivial on one side like
unlike a pathway proof
proof
um yeah but the main the key observation
is that in a face like gray at least one
of the two children the one that's the
face you drop in dimension by at least
one
I say that one drops in dimension
um yeah and so if we want to show that
face like stabbing planes is equal to
cutting planes we'll rely on this Lemma
by Shriver from the 80s
um which basically says that if we have
a cutting planes refutation of a face
then there's a way to lift it up to
um a derivation on the initial Polito so
if we have a face so let's say that ax
grain equal to B is valid for the
polytope so every point in the polytope
lies on that lies to the right of like a
experience of the b or like satisfies to
B
um so if you look at the face ax equal
to B that is we throw in a x less than b
um
then if we have a refutation of this
face
then we can derive that ax is actually
we can lift this refutation into a small
derivation from the initial polytope
that axis Grand with the B plus one so I
can show you this in a picture
um okay uh yeah so here's this is gonna
be my face
um
so I have ax grain equal the B is valid
for every point in the polytope every
Point satisfies it and now I'm going to
look at the face ax equal to B that is I
throw in the inequality X less than or
equal to B
um
this is the face here
and so I'm going to suppose that I have
a cutting plane's refutation just up the
face
so yeah so we have a bunch of CG Cuts
here that slowly rule out
um
eventually drive it
so we have this refutation of the face
and then from it we can derive a
refutation of the face starting from the
initial polytip
we looked at this face we lifted this
refutation up to a derivation of ax
squaring with a B plus one starting from
this polytope p
the the size of the derivation is going
to be equal to the size of of the
refutation of the face
and so this this
is going to change the coefficients and
this is where this coefficient comes up
uh this coefficient blow up comes so we
have to basically we take this
refutation and we shift half spaces
around to uh to use this dilemma
um
and we're going to recursively apply the
Lemma and that's going to cause the
coefficients to blow up
okay
um yeah so now we want to show that face
like stabbing planes is equal to cutting
planes using this Lemma so we fix a face
like stabbing cleanse proof
we take an in order traversal and we
repeatedly apply this Lemma in order to
lift
um refutations of faces up to
derivations on the higher polytope right
so at the leaf this is just a ref like a
trivial sort of refutation of the spot
the polytubes just empty and we lift it
up to derive
um you know maybe this is ax less than
or equal to B we derive ax greater than
the B plus one now we're down here we
keep lifting it up and we're slowly like
unraveling this tree into a into a
cutting planes proof hey so for example
P1 is a face of P0
uh
P2 is going to be a face of P1 and so on
and so forth so we just unravel this
tree into a cutting planes proof
um
and each of these recursive steps can
blow up the coefficients
I don't see a way to bound it
uh and then the second step is we want
to show that you can turn any low
coefficient stabbing plants proof into a
face like stabbing planes proof so
remember a face like stabbing plants
proof is one where one of the two sides
of the of the query is just a face of
the polytop and and this thing is we
just kind of do the dumbest thing
possible okay so we we start with a a
query in the stabbing planes proof
expressed under the b a x squared equal
to B plus one like this
um and we want to convert it to a face
light query and what we're just going to
do is add a bunch of translates of this
query until we hit a face
so
so just like this actually
I think these queries might actually be
wrong
um so basically this here is a face we
hit the edge of the polytope
um so we first query this thing and then
on one branch we query this thing
so on so forth
okay so that's a face yeah
and we're going to recursively refute
each of these translates using the old
stabbing planes proof right so
um this one
this uh Branch here this this sub proof
here completely ruled out all of the
polytope over here and so we can just
apply it down here and
refute uh each of these more refined
branches
and then on the other side we just use
the uh the other sub proof
okay so yeah we just want to turn
something into a face like stabbing
planes proof we we have a branch maybe
it's not face like what we're just going
to do is we're going to start at like
the nearest face of the polytopal we're
just going to add translates to work our
way in
um
very yep small coefficients are used to
show that there aren't very many
translate yes yeah thank you I was just
about to say that yes so
um yeah so the width so if we want to
add all these translates
um I want to say that the number of
translates that we're going to add to
this polytope is going to be
proportional to it's obviously
proportional to the width of this slab
but the width of this lab is like
inverse inversely related to the size of
the coefficients if you have really
small coefficients then this slab might
be really small but if if the
coefficient is so large the width of
this lab is going to be pretty large and
so you're going to get you're not going
to need as many translates if the
coefficients
so then you just rehearse on each of
these guys and you keep applying the
same thing
and the recursive blow up that you get
is going to be proportional to the width
of the slab
um and also the diameter of the polyte
because you're just gonna you have to
cover one side of the poly dope each
time
uh so this brings me to kind of a weird
property of these proofs that we get out
of this
okay so we showed that these face like
Statin planes proofs are equal to
cutting planes
um
but what this theorem actually does is
converts pretty shallow stabbing planes
proofs so like tree doesn't have very
long depth large depth into very deep
cutting planes proofs and this happens
because we're taking an inorder
traversal of the stabbing planes Tree on
each branch and it unrolls the thing
into a very deep
um cutting plants proof
so for example the we have the stabbing
planes proofs of Satan
um these ones have size quasi polynomial
and uh poly logarithmic depth
um however after applying this
translation this converts uh the proof
into a cutting planes proof that has
both depth and size quasi-polynomial and
this is weird because
um there
for any unsatisfiable CNF formula there
is a cutting planes proof that has maybe
has exponential sides but has linear
depth so for every unsatisfiable CNF
formula we have a linear depth
um
uh cutting plants proof so this is kind
of a Beyond worst case step
uh these these are very strange
um
approves
uh and so we made this conjecture at the
end of the paper which is that any
sub-exponential size cutting planes
proof
um of the site and formulas has to
actually have this Beyond worst case
depth has to have super polynomial depth
or or even polynomial death like super
linear depth would be interesting
um
yeah
and this would be like a really weird
structure of these proofs and
um
for those of you who are like me various
that didn't realize that there was an
upper Bound for the site and formulas
this would maybe under explain why we
didn't find this upper bound because
it's making cutting plants behave in a
way that seems extremely unnatural
um
yeah okay so I just want to say a few
things on this conjecture
um yeah so uh
basically any
um
any CNF formula uh has a linear depth
proof but it must it might have
exponential size
um this brings you to like these super
critical side steps trade-offs this
conjecture is about
super critical trade-offs
um in particular uh so a super critical
trade-off is one where you bound some
measure of a proof and it causes another
measure to go beyond worst case so for
example in this conjecture here I want
to say that if I bound the size of
cutting planes proofs to the citing
formulas it causes the depth to go Way
Beyond the worst case linear upper band
um so in complexity thus far we we don't
really have many examples of these
trade-offs
um the first few examples were for
um there was a trade-off between a super
critical tryout between resolution size
and space it was also one by rasprov
that does a trade-off between tree-like
resolution size and width we're going to
come back to this one
um and then there's been uh several
other ones between space and size and
also width for resolution and polynomial
calculus we don't really have many
examples of this strange behavior of
groups
um so in a follow-up paper uh we proved
the first supercritical size depth
trade-offs
um
uh and he's held for resolution this
kdnf resolution proof system and also
for cutting plants this is good if we
want to prove this conjecture
um I'm going to say a few words on that
so this Builds on this proof by rasprov
in 2016.
um
actually it can it can be viewed as a
pretty simple extension of it
um
and I'm going to say why we don't
immediately get this conjecture from it
and why it seems like this resolving
this conjecture might be a little bit
more difficult
so here's the statement of the theorem a
little bit more formally
um so it's it's a really nice kind of
smooth trade-off
um so we can show that for each of these
proof systems I'll I'll Define it for a
resolution here and then the the
trade-offs for cutting planes and press
K are similar but
basically the same uh basically there's
a CNF formula we have a parameter c
um such that there's resolution proofs
of
roughly into the C uh complexity
um however if we want the size to be
like roughly sub exponential
um then the depth times logo size has to
satisfy this relation here so if we
bound the size of the proof to be sort
of sub-exponential this turns out to
like like what happens is that this
forces the depth of this proof also to
be like roughly uh like two to the end
of the Epsilon ish
so we get like these proofs that are
um have you know slightly sub
exponential size but depth that's also
basically so extensional and and so it's
just like one long skinny path these are
behaving very strangely
um and I'm going to say a few words on
the the proof here uh so you that you
can see why it doesn't resolve this
conjecture and why I think some sort of
new techniques are going to be required
um so the proof idea is pretty simple uh
we begin with a formula which has small
size but requires large depth in
resolution
um so for example the pebbling formulas
they have linear size but require near
linear depth
and then the whole idea is to just take
this formula and sort of compress the
number of variables while maintaining
the hardness of the formula so I'm going
to shrink the number of variables from
Little n to capital n capital N is going
to be way smaller than little n it's
going to be approximately like n to the
C for that parameter C there
uh and we're gonna maintain that the
that there's an upper bound roughly in
um
uh order n maybe uh
it's approximately order n and a lower
bound of n log n uh but these are in
terms of the initial variables
so the uncompressed variables so we've
just taken our formula Shrunk the number
of variables but maintained the
trade-off basically
um yeah so we want to take n variables
compress it to capital N which is going
to be n to the one over C ining number
of variables compared to the initial
ones and
um in order to do this what we want is
we want that it should be difficult for
resolution to be able to differentiate
between the
um original formula and this compressed
formula and so it can't really use uh
any information about the fact that
we've really compressed it in order to
solve this formula
um so how do we do this
um roughly the idea is the way I like to
think about it is we take the the CNF
Formula F and we compose it with this
pseudo-random generator these Nissan
Victor Sim generator so
um more formally that we replace we look
at a graph where the left variables are
the initial variables the right
variables or the new variables and we
stick an expand around here
um and we replace each old variable with
an xor of its neighbors in the details
so for example here I think this is
so X this should be X6 is going to be
replaced with the xor of Y2 and Y3
and so basically what we can show after
doing this is that resolution really
can't differentiate between this new
composed formula
xorified formula and the initial formula
and so we still basically get this this
depth lower bound
um however uh the number of variables
has shrunk uh by a massive factor and so
we get this huge trade-off we just
amplify this trade-off to a uh
to something much larger
so
um then we can get the trade-offs for uh
kdf resolution and cutting planes by a
similar by just lifting the same
technique just using known lifting
theorems
uh so yep
what does it mean to differentiate
uh very oh so uh BJ's question is what
does it mean to differentiate and uh I
mean that very very informally
um like all I mean here is that
resolution still requires like little n
over log n
um uh complexity in order like size in
order to refute this composed formula
even though this composed formula has
been obfuscated and compressed in such a
way that the the number of variables has
dropped uh
by a massive Factor like you can set C
to be uh something that depends on n
okay
um
yeah so then the question is can I use
um this super critical trade-off
um approach in order to show that any
cutting planes in order to resolve this
conjecture so show that any cutting
planes proof of the site and formulas
has to that's small has to have very
very large depths
[Music]
um
so it's not obvious to me that this
would work because it fails basically
the first step
um so we start with a formula that is in
order to prove these supercritical
trade-offs we start with the formula
that Witnesses a small size depth
trade-off for
um uh for resolution right like the
pebbling formulas they had linear size
proofs but very large depth and then we
Amplified this however the site and
formulas are already extremely hard for
resolution that require exponential size
resolution proofs and maximal depth so
we don't have this trade-off to amplify
so we can't do it by just lifting from
resolution maybe this strategy could
work but it's
it seems like you have to implement it
for cutting planes and that seems uh
challenging
um yeah so we need a it seems like we
need a more direct approach than
starting with resolution proving the
trade-off there and using these lifting
theorems to lift it up to Stronger proof
systems
um so the last thing I want to mention
is that towards this we tried to prove
uh try to maybe start progress on this
question
um by proving by developing a way to
prove lower bounds on the depth of
cutting planes proofs
um that is sort of like uh has a nice
geometric flavor that we're
hopeful maybe could be extended to this
um and in doing that
um yeah we proved linear depth lower
bounds on the same formulas even for uh
semantic cutting planes this extends
this work by brush oppenheim and all
and yeah it uses a very simple uh
geometric argument which is
kind of what we need in order to start
analyzing cutting planes directly rather
than
these techniques that use use more
communication and it's not so clear that
super critical trade-offs
will be as easy to obtain for those
communication
uh so that's the end of my talk I just
want to end with a couple of open
problems so first is to approve or
disprove this conjecture
um then second can we improve this
simulation of stabbing plants by cutting
planes to from uh low coefficients to
high coefficients I think this is a
great question I
I kind of waffle whether it's true or
not but I think it's probably I hope
it's true I think it would be very cool
um or alternatively prove a separation
between the two
[Music]
um
uh can we uh so that there's a there's a
generalization of these stabbing plans
Bruce to a dag-like model called res CP
and can we prove a separation between
stabbing planes and red CP or is this uh
even for local efficient seven planes or
is there a simulation I don't know that
seems unlikely
um
so uh there's this work by Albert
who shows that I think it can be
interpreted as saying that cutting
planes
cannot simulate rescp maybe
quasi-polynomially so there's this I
think that people they show a
upper band for the color formulas
um in kdnf resolution which can be
implemented in redcp
um and you know the click color formulas
are known to be hard for cutting plates
um oh and one other question that I
wanted to ask and
forgot to include here is like uh
can we develop some sort of solver based
on this stabbing plane system
um seems I mean obviously choosing how
to Branch
um
is difficult but it's a very clean uh
proof system and it can directly
simulate dpll it can do the same sort of
branching that dpll is doing it's it's
very like branching-based proof system
um yeah can we can we generate some sort
of
offer based on this framework
uh thanks
so no I will repeat the question
any questions so
in a way this system the studying planes
is a little bit like the the proof
system behind linear programming right
so in a way when linear programming be
like the implementation with all the you
know your heuristics and everything of
studying planes or you think there are
other ways yeah but I was I was hoping
you could do some sort of like Clause
learning sort of analog but I think that
they introduced some plus learning I
mean the people in integer linear
programming they put in a lot of things
you know and I think okay some kind of
close learning he's there too but you
know okay okay yeah
I don't know too too much about it
you know the question if you have any
references I'd really like to hear
yes awesome so
um I think uh
a lot of ILP algorithms are actually
like closely held industrial secrets so
are we actually aware of what they're
actually doing
laughs
not all of them some of them okay
there is concrete information about some
of them so in Oaxaca a few years ago
there was a workshop and there was a guy
that implemented into a shared linear
Pro uh programming and I talked to him
and he gave a talk that is proudly
recorded you know so you can look in
there yeah yeah yeah I really like to
see that
I mean so there is one open source
solver skip in Berlin which is not as
good as the commercial flow Source
solvers so this is a difference from the
SAT Community where I think it's fair to
say that the Academia solvers are are
really competitive this is not the case
in mixed into their linear programming
but skip is pretty good and and in
particular also a number of people who
are working on the closed source source
solvers happen to sit like exactly in
the same buildings as the ski people do
and they talk and they collaborate so
it's sort of it's semi-known I think
what the ingredients are but maybe like
exactly the secret sauce how they
combine it is not fully known
okay
I just wonder if there are people in
this room not know about sort of
uh
benchmarks that separate IP from sat
solvers because uh when I you know in in
my uh section about sad solvers I I had
100 Benchmark problems and I and and I
took them to my to my friends who do uh
uh integer programming and I said how
many of these are trivial for you and
you know and and and they and well I had
one problem which which I which what was
it called um
um
a good
yeah digital tomography
and the the IP solvers uh uh you know
wiped me out I couldn't solve these
problems with sad at all
um uh I hope about it I know 100
problems I think I I think they did very
well on on maybe seven of them but I was
glad to know that it wasn't 97 if you
know what I mean
I don't know of any benchmarks that
separate they're like practical
benchmarks
yeah uh the story that I know
from Kevin Leyton Brown's is it
originally people when us was running
the Broadband uh the reverse Broadband
auction they originally tried to solve
those instances with
operation research methods and nothing
worked
apparently and then they were able to do
really good job the set solvers plus
some heuristics on top that the stories
that I know I know for the people who
have better stories
more comments or questions
um so in smt a world there has been some
work where
uh called cuts from proofs
uh where um
the date the linear approximation uh use
a LPS or like Simplex method to solve
and see if there is a a solution and
when they don't find an integer solution
they try to produce an equality as a
proof
that did
there was not an integer solution and
then they branch on that equality
like X Plus y equals one yeah so are you
aware of it and seems
interestingly related to that and I'm
wondering like if they have done
to integrate that kind of method Maybe
stabbing planes can also be integrated
in smt solving yeah yeah I'm not quite
sure but that sounds that sounds very
similar to yeah what you would do here I
guess like you just you solve the lp
either gives you a solution or it
doesn't it doesn't you get like a cut
that removes some some feasible region
you rehearse on it
I'm not
I have to admit I don't know much about
the smt literature yeah I don't know the
exact details but they uh they do it
some kind of uh normalization find a
particular uh normal form of the Tableau
of the Simplex
novel form and from that they can
extract this
unsatisfiable that uh current how we can
yeah that sounds similar too
yeah
thank you
time for one more question
there are no more questions let's go to
the coffee break before we think Noah
again
[Applause]